hey spencer ackerman with wired.com here
on a nun seasonably warm Saturday
morning ahead of Super Bowl Sunday we're
at Marine Corps Air Station in Cherry
Point North Carolina where we're about
to get on the USS Wasp a marine
amphibious assault ship that's going to
take part in the biggest amphibious
assault exercise of the last ten years
let's go board a ship
Ross it is my pleasure to introduce at
Long John greener xxx Chief of Naval
Operations of the United States Navy
what you guys are doing we're sort of in
our head back in 2006-2007 bold
alligator is a result of all of that
brainstorm and way back when I went to
another job and commandant Conway at the
time called down and he said I want you
guys to get ready to do a fleet exercise
of amphibious operations so here we are
so I was really excited this thing
finally came to fruition and your guys
are getting it done and I commend you
for it it's going great to be able to
get some of our latest stuff and fibia
stops out there and seeing this
Bluegreen field has been a long time
coming